CAPABLE OF LEARNING ANYTHING,
THE COUNTRY WOULD NOT LOOK LIKE
IT IS TODAY.
CONGRESSMAN MATT, THE FLOOR THE
KEY WATCHING CAREFULLY TODAY, IF
YOU WERE TO SUM UP WHAT WE
LEARNED TODAY FROM THESE
HEARINGS AND THEY WERE TOUTED
THROUGHOUT THE DAY AS PIVOTAL.
A BOMBSHELL, IED, BLOWTORCH!
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR SUMMARY?
>> DONALD TRUMP IS SKEPTICAL OF
FOREIGN AID AND WASHINGTON LOVES
FOREIGN AID BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
POLITICIANS AND AMBASSADORS AND
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRATS TO DO OUR
FAVORITE THEN, GIVE AWAY OTHER
PEOPLE'S MONEY.
DONALD TRUMP WAS ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE UKRAINE
BECAUSE IT WAS THE THIRD AND
MOST CORRUPT COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
OF COURSE, EVERYBODY IN
WASHINGTON WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT RUSSIA IS ALWAYS OUR ENEMY
AND UKRAINE IS THE FRIEND WHEN
THE REALITY IS FAR MORE COMPLEX
THAN THAT.
REPUBLICANS DO THEIR BEST WORK
TODAY WHEN THEY DROVE A WEDGE
BETWEEN THAT WHICH SONDLAND
RESUMED IN THE WISDOM AS PART OF
THE DIPLOMATIC WORLD IN WHICH HE
ACTUALLY HEARD AND SAW.
I THINK THAT MIKE TURNER, JOHN
RADCLIFF, JORDAN DID A GOOD JOB
SHOWING THAT THE ONLY DIRECTION
THAT AMBASSADOR SONDLAND GOT
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT WANT
ANYTHING, HE JUST WANTED
ZELENSKY TO FULFILL THE COMMENCE
IN THE CAMPAIGN TO CLEAN UP THE
COUNTRY.
IF THEY JUST DID NOT SIT WELL
WITH PERMANENT WASHINGTON AND
THAT'S WHY THE SHOW GOES ON.
>> Tucker: SO, WOULD YOU SAY
THAT'S REALLY THE TAKE AWAY?
THIS IS A DEBATE ABOUT THE
POLICY?
CLOAKED IN A LOT OF HIGH-MINDED
LANGUAGE, DESIGNED TO HIDE THE
BALL FROM THE REST OF US.
BUT, REALLY, THEY DON'T LIKE
WHAT DONALD TRUMP WANTS TO DO
WITH AMERICAN POLICY TOWARDS
UKRAINE AND RUSSIA.
>> IT'S THE WORST KIND OF
GROUPTHINK THE ENEMY IS
SHOWS AN ENEMY
UPGRADED NISSAN ELEMENT OF
WASHING MERGE, AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN, YOU GET THE SENSE THAT
ALL OF THEIR BELIEFS ARE THEN
THE PRESIDENT'S BELIEFS AND THEY
CAN GO, SAY, WELL, I SURMISED
SOME CONCLUSION ON THE GLOBAL
STAGE AND BECAUSE SOME WEEKS
AGO, I SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT,
IN FACT, IT'S MY BELIEF THAT
THIS OUGHT TO BE THE CASE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION STANDPOINT.
REALITY IS FAR DIFFERENT.
I THINK GORDON SONDLAND'S, YOU
SEE SOMEONE WHO IS AN
INTER-MEDDLER WHO IS A BIT OUT
OF HIS LANE AND SOMEONE WHO
NEVER, EVER, GOT DIRECTION FROM
THE PRESIDENT OR ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION TO DIRECT IN
THE QUID PRO QUO FOR A DEBATE OF
THE MEDIA, WHAT THEY DO, THEY
TRY TO CONFLATE WHAT SOMEONE IS
FEELINGS ARE OR THE BELIEF IS
ABOUT POLICY AND COMPARED TO
WHAT THEY ACTUALLY OBSERVE AND
BE ADMISSIBLE WHEN YOU TRY TO
SCRUTINIZE EVIDENCE.
IT'S SOMETHING AS SERIOUS AS